on poursuit avec l'économiste clément
gignac et le fiscaliste le godbout à la
suite des annonces aujourd'hui du
gouvernement fédéral devait parler d'une
famille le cas avant la pause là avec
des enfants
pour une famille monoparentale les
bonifications d'aujourd'hui ça veut dire
quoi
elles sont prenez une famille avec un
revenu typique la famille monoparentale
35 me de revenus ça peut paraître
modeste mais c'est le revenu médian
d'une famille monoparentale avec un
enfant on recevrait 750 $ de plus juste
pour le crédit de tps et 300 $ à la
location canadienne pour enfin pour
parce qu'on a un seul enfant
donc au total ou dans les six prochaines
semaines on recevrait 1050 $ de plus en
aide de l'état dans cette situation-là
très intéressant donc on a parlé des
familles on ne parlait des familles
monoparentales on ne parlait des
travailleurs des chômeurs parlons un
petit peu des aînés luc ottawa veut
réduire de 25% le retrait minimal prévu
pour 2020 des fonds enregistré de revenu
de retraite les faire pousser exit donc
les gens comprennent lorsqu'on a un réel
passé un certain âge à 71 ans il faut
convertir sont réellement faire est là
chaque année on a d un minimum de
retrait est obligé et ce minimum la
mettons qu'on aurait dû sortir un pour
le pour l'année en cours dix mille
dollars
mais là on va produire 25% de bons mots
pour sortir 25% de moins donc seulement
sortir 7500 donc laisser plus d'argent
de le faire et espérer que des
prochaines années procure de meilleurs
rendements que le pouce et continue de
croître et donc avoir moins être moins
pénalisant pour les aînés parce que les
mains on veut savoir si la bourse vont
encore baisser
un acte et je servais gérald ok je vais
vraiment me l'irb à la réalité les
personnes qui s'est vraiment c'est quoi
le creux gardons l'esprit
qu'effectivement on voit une récession
qui est déjà commencée c'est un aperçu
de contraction des tu déconnes mais ça
peut durer quelques mois mais c'est pas
une dépression le on part d'une
contraction de l'activité économique
cette arrivée à 11 reprises sa boîte la
12e reprise depuis maintenant la seconde
guerre mondiale mais il ya des fois que
et le chômage aux pommes pour beaucoup
d'entre eux aussi
ça va être intéressant plein
intellectuelle systémique parce que la
définition qui soit match c'est
quelqu'un qui personne un poème et qui
se met également en disponibilité ayant
cherché un autre emploi or dans bien des
cas c'est un congé sans solde
on va recevoir un chèque du gouvernement
ou les de recevoir un chèque de notre
employeur est-ce qu'il va avoir un bon
c'est les demandes de prestations
d'assurance chômage se savoir une
explosion mais genre de voir sur le
chômage 4 à la bourse
quand on est en récession un marché
baissier un moyen de 6 35% environ le et
on est le 10 e mais est ce que oui est
écoutée sur lequel son premier ne sais
pas normalement une solution mais le
labour comme elle est dégoûtée elle a
beaucoup de volatilité
on ne voit des choses qu'on n'a jamais
vu le trou sur le banc romain et s'y
trouve à l'utilité puis si la beauce
attrapé la grippe elle aussi je ne
serais pas surpris qu'en fin de semaine
le g7 vont se réunir il va voir décision
concertée on peut pas une pause a permis
de rester ouverts donc que si washington
décidé confirme yop un intérêt toronto
phil fait que je maintiens que le g7
on va se parler les autorités
réglementaires londres tokyo francfort
toronto et certaines décisions
c'est pas impossible qu'il fait ce
prénom cet homme on a fermé trois jours
oui parce que les uns paniqué c'est un
peu différent parce que certains
qu'aussi est affectée évidemment parce
qu'ils étaient passés cette fois ci on
vous dit que le petit investisseur qui
détient mettons des titres bancaires que
ça fait cinq ans qu'on dit inquiet tout
repos sont bien capitalisées ils sont
brésiliens la récession que tout à coup
sa perte de carvin pour simple que huit
membres parce qu'ils paniquent places
co2 s'est fait nommer les huit parfums
sur les valeurs refuges baisse en ce
moment c'est un leurre est professeur
parce qu'actuellement c'est les
algorithmes lit et femmes puissent édité
par les ordinateurs et là on s'y perd en
sorte au pot dont ils sont sur le point
de les garder
dites vous qu il n en seront pas d'avs
ans et vont régner qui vont le faire
mais s'il le faut on reçoit samedi matin
par une annonce dimanche
si ça continue est ok mais pour
l'instant ce n'est pas un scénario
melting pot exclu on reporte donc
nos paiements d'impôts 31 ou si on a un
seul de du fait donc le gouvernement du
québec l'avait annoncé plus tôt cette
semaine le fédéral a emboîté le pas avec
des des paramètres initialement
différents mets donc on a jusqu'au 1er
juin pour produire sa déclaration
donc on enlève aux gens le stress de
devoir produire leurs déclarations et on
enlève le stress de paix mardi à mes bas
vous avez jusqu'au 31 août pour faire
les paiements pour ceux qui ont des
soldes du donc et québec 17h50 et
rapidement le ministre des finances
rapidement sur twitter et je vais faire
des mêmes dates que le gouvernement
puisque fédéral donc ça c'est réglé
je le dis moi j'aime bien rappeler aux
jeunes si vous attendez un remboursement
et que vous avez la chance de produire
votre déclaration faite là parce que le
remboursement va arriver plus tôt donc
c'est important de le garder en tête
voilà est donc aujourd'hui on va
terminer là dessus aujourd'hui c'est
l'aide aux canadiens plus tard ce sera
la relance de l'économie qui est un
moment donné on va comptabiliser pour
savoir où et où on en est avec le
déficit budgétaire
doit on revenir prom 1 150 200 milliards
le couple de jours je vais suggérer que
faudrait penser en termes de 85
milliards j'ai rendu que les chiffres
augmentent parce que le gratin fréquence
milliards de défaire regarder quand ces
rentiers ikea depuis des hôtels jamais
su imaginer voir des shows de plein air
se satisfait si tout ça donc c'est
évident que le groupe américain va
pouvoir financer les cons pays et rien
parce qu'un jour il y aura un vaccin qui
soit un jour on vous voir sur ses
voyages et puis si vous combinez rien
puis et puis d'hôtel puis annonce
nicolas dans le futur je vous arrête
parce que on va recevoir été clément
gignac merci hugo debout merci vous
étiez l'un ps de lyon voir clair merci